ayer había mucha celebración alegría
aquí daban por hecho que como que donald
trump iba a ganar
florida pues ya daban por hecho que
también iba a ganar o que ibas iba a
facilitar esa reelección por parte de la
campaña republicana
hemos visto después que pasaran las
horas que no ha sido así ahora hay una
tensa calma y están a la expectativa
para ver qué es lo que va a pasar a
partir de ahora sin embargo ellos
esa es ambiente era sobre todo a
seguidores en fervientes de donald trump
eso sí los demócratas prefirieron
permanecer en silencio durante toda la
noche y ahora sí están muy pendientes en
ambos lados de cómo evoluciona este
conteo de votos y también viendo de qué
manera ha podido incidir el voto latino
en esta elección especialmente aquí en
el sur de la florida